Зі скількома чоловіками вона мала секс,
Юлія навіть не знає. Десятьма, дванадцятьма
чи навіть більше, припускає вона.  Щоночі.
Упродовж років 30-річна румунка продавала своє тіло.
Як повія у борделях, барах, на панелі.
Школу Юлія не закінчила. У 14 років народила першу дитину.
Згодом ще одну.
Заробітку від прибирання на життя в Румунії не вистачало.
ож вона вбачала шанс на краще життя
у роботі за кордоном - як повія.
Я знала, що буде важко, але було ще гірше, ніж я собі уявляла.
Передусім перші три тижні були страшенно важкими.
Усе, що треба було робити.
Проте я завжди думала про своїх дітей і казала собі,
що я тут, аби допомогти моїй родині й дітям.
Вона працювала у Швейцарії, Греції та Франції.
Нині вона вже п'ять років у Штутгарті.
певний момент вона зрозуміла, що більше не може.
Хоче просто геть. У березні вона обслуговує останнього клієнта.
Що ж далі?
Юлія та такі ж жінки у скруті отримують допомогу
в об'єднанні Sisters e.V.
Це консультація для повій,
які хочуть покінчити з цим ремеслом.
Непримітна будівля посеред кварталу будинків розпусти у Штутгарті.
Ця організація допомагає жінкам знайти нову роботу,
підтримує їх фінансово,
допоки вони не стануть на ноги.
Є тут і медична консультація.
А ще завжди є хтось, готовий вислухати.
Коли жінка хоче припинити проституцію і не має сутенера,
якщо її не тримають у заручниках,
тоді вона дійсно може залишити бордель.
Однак вона не знайде місця для ночівлі,
не знайде нікого, хто б її нагодував.
Вона не може прости піти у якесь відомство
і просити про прихисток та допомогу на проживання.
Вона не може отримувати соціальну допомогу.
Тому це так важко.
Максимум, що їй можуть дати - квиток на батьківщину.
Юлія каже, що сутенера в неї ніколи не було.
Це радше виняток з правил.
З кожного клієнта вона отримувала 30 євро за 20 хвилин.
Я працювала переважно до третьої ночі.
Довше я витримати не могла.
Однак були й жінки, які працювали всю ніч.
Вони вживали алкоголь та наркотики,
аби у напівпритомному стані все витримати.
Адже аби оплачувати кімнату, треба було заробляти
щонайменше 130 євро на день.
А ще ж потрібно було щотижня відсилати гроші додому.
Заощаджувати практично не вдавалося.
Тож час від час жінку охоплювала паніка.
Нині вона все ще потерпає від цього.
Згадуючи  пережите, я б не наважилася зробити це знову.
Я знову й знову думала про те,
що треба знайти щось інше.
Але знайти іншу роботу не вдавалося.
Тепер вона знову працює прибиральницею.
Цю роботу їй допомогли знайти в об'єднанні Sisters.
Юлія пишається собою. Вона насолоджується денним світлом
та тим, що не мусить носити вульгарний одяг.
Вона викинула речі, які зазвичай одягають тут,
у штутгартському кварталі Леонардсфіртель.
Удень вулиці тут безлюдні. Увечері натомість бари та будинки розпусти переповнені.
Перед дверима чатують м'язисті чоловіки,
всередині очікують клієнтів жінки.
Більшість - зі Східної Європи, як і Юлія.
Скільки їх там, достеменно не знає ніхто.
Усе це для Юлії залишилося в минулому.
Нагадуванням є лише старі фото.
Проте показувати їх жінка не хоче.  Окрім оцієї світлини з мамою.
Це фото вона любить, на відміну від тих, де вона одягнена, як повія.
Сьогодні вона - вже інша людина.